our next guest he couldn't live up to
his father's name as a football player
so he turned to basketball a role player
on the 1991 Duke team he provided great
support to Christian Laettner he was
lucky enough to be the recipient of a
brilliant value from Bobby Hurley
against Kansas route to a national title
you may remember him he was the guy with
the kid his play haircut he went on to
play 18 years as a defensive stopper
later in his career since we could get
Christian Laettner Bobby Hurley or Allah
be welcome
[Music]
basketball analyst rent on the call at
the Final Four national title game for
the fifth consecutive year what bothers
you the most about that introduction
there we had later on
that was yesterday two days ago I never
know when he's serious when he's joking
like he's cocky he's humble I like I
don't know how you read him when you
played that Duke with him right
I think he's more humble now but when we
played you know look there's so much
about Laettner that's been discussed and
you know he was this he was that he was
a great teammate he really was and he
was just super super come everything was
a competition everything whose bag would
come out first at the airport you know
you know who could see a squirrel first
on cam everything was he was just hyper
competitive and I don't feel like he's
as competitive now but he said he told
you first day I want you to dunk on me
yeah no idea I saw that it is true he
would uh
and he would try to contest and try to
block it and you know it was a little
bit different little bit weird the most
people don't say try to dunk on me but
he was just competitive he wanted to try
to meet at the rim and see if he could
block my dunk and then I think after a
while and I was dunking on him pretty
easily and then talking a little trash
to him so that ended you know after that
point but that was Christian I mean he
I'll say this he got more excited for my
great plays than anybody else I think of
that image from the tournament when RJ
Barrett had a reverse dunk yes jumping
up and down like that was Christian so
he was complicated in a lot of ways but
he was a great teammate and a lot of fun
to play with and we did that documentary
he did it the only body Hey later and
but did you have teammates at least but
he settled me for two hours I said great
things about them and they just look
like five minutes
that supported their their thesis and
ran with it but what did you have
players who you played with in the NBA
that asked you about him uh yeah I think
so there were some players early on who
asked about him and he was just one of a
coach he's an enigma yeah he is he is a
little bit but he's he's a I think he's
a good person at heart he had great
things to say about you no no I mean
look I have great things to say there's
a story we played at Canisius his senior
year in Buffalo
he's everybody's all-american we go to
Buffalo they give him the key to the
city
we'd go out in the first half you know
we're blowing them out he's taken he
took one shot at halftime I remember
coach getting on I'm like hey with this
side this game is for you you look like
you don't want to play and he's like I
want my hometown to see how good my
teammates are and so like there's that
side of Laettner that doesn't get played
up but he was competitive he he put it
all on his shoulders he endured a lot of
abuse on the road but as a teammate he
really was a great team made fun to be
around good Bobby Hurley say the same
thing yeah I mean look they had their
moments I mean just like any you know
I'm sure like the D&S I'm sure you guys
you know get it get after a while yeah
but I mean look they hit they played
great together and I think there was
more good a lot more good than bad but
they had their moments
I mean look crazy no we had our moments
I mean Christian but you didn't fight
did you all the time
we fought all the time like I mean like
throwing punches every okay so I'm gonna
tell you a little story so my first ACC
game we're getting ready to play
Virginia at Virginia and we're in
Christian's room Christian's rooming
with Tony lang who was my normal
roommate but we had different roommates
on a rope and the beds were pushed apart
and we're fighting each other like
there's about five or six of us and
we're taking turns fighting each other
like what how does it start where you're
I don't even know how it started but the
manager knocks on the door a couple
times we're making all this noise we're
wrestling we're fighting it was almost
like you fight each other and we'd go at
it and no punches are thrown but we're
wrestling and trying to like whatever
and so we go out the next day and we
lose
like 25 like we get blown so afternoon
gang so we bust back to Durham no one
says a word for three hours pulled up to
Cameron and coach says I want everybody
taped and ready in 15 minutes
and that was the worst practice that
I've ever been a part of and I broke my
nose in that practice and so I managed
to stay away from Christian on the road
from that moment on but but yeah I mean
that we were kids we were juvenile we
did silly things and obviously things
that in the social media age you can't
do now but we fought every day we
Christian could actually fight he was
good with his hands used to box growing
up so we slap box and you know we were
kids we had fun and you know and so but
he was you know he could what is it
yeah you certainly talk that's for sure
yes grant Hill's with us Turner Sports
basketball analyst and of course on the
call for the final four national title
game Tuesday's poll question was most
talented do player of all time Paulie
yes okay the most talented Duke player
of all time is this just a way for the
media to get scions name into whatever
their show is because you're the most
talented player that I think ever played
it to yeah you know Christian said that
as well oh do you think you're more
talented than Jaya I mean it's hard to
make this debate I mean really when you
start comparing different eras because
what Zion has done what Marvin Bagley
did what Kyrie did as freshmen we didn't
do that back then you know his greatest
Christian was his junior and senior year
his first year he played with Danny fair
Danny Ferry was College Player of the
Year Christian was in a comp a
complementary role much like I was in a
complementary role and so that's what
happen waited their turn and so and so
to think that this kid can come out and
and play at this level as a freshman
National Player of the Year all this
hype all this attention on him as an 18
year old like we never went through any
of that you know I was shielded by
Laettner Laettner was shielded by
a fairy was shielded by Johnny Dawkins
so it was a different tension she's a
real different time so in saying that I
mean because I would look at this and
this is the argument I would make
let me see Zion as a finished product at
Duke or at least have a couple more
years because you were a finished
product at Duke Christian was a finished
product at Duke Johnny played longer you
know Battier played longer so we saw you
guys became men Saiyans 18 right Zions
21 or 22 what kind of player is he while
he's still playing in college I mean he
may be considered not only the maybe the
greatest Duke player but could possibly
be the greatest you know of all time I
mean you just you never know
I think his potential is his athleticism
his explosiveness have you been around
him yeah no I hadn't been around a much
this year but with the tournament run
you know with him and you know the thing
that was impressive was like it with all
that's going on and all the exposure was
almost like he's oblivious to that like
he and RJ and their kids and but I like
Zion he celebrates his teammates RJ is
not as celebratory I think Zion loves
playing basketball
I think RJ loves shooting love score no
I mean I think I think we all celebrate
each other in different ways
I think Sion is more expressive he's
definitely comes across as more the
emotional more of the vocal guy you know
I think RJ is a little bit more cerebral
in terms of his personality but like one
in one story I heard with the people
that do that with all the exposure he
was getting he went to the SI D and said
look it's too much about me it's got to
be about the team yeah and so there's
just like he's genuine he's pure he's a
great teammate and you know I think he
has obviously a great future in front of
not because of his talent but because of
his his work ethic and the right
mentality I don't know how many guys are
on this list who have guarded Michael
Jordan LeBron James and Kobe Bryant
right so you're on that list because you
didn't normally guard Jordan I thought
that was a Carolina sir no no
we wouldn't do that don't play with fire
we wouldn't do that - okay but if you
said and you would be the one of the
ultimate people to ask like the best
offensive player you faced right who
would that be like the toughest to guard
you got to go with George I didn't guard
Jordan a lot but when I did it was
definitely Jordan but she Kobe wants to
know so Colby was tough as I guarded
Kobe a lot and I was sort of like on the
sun's like that was my role to guard
Kobe and and so that was Kobe's
relentless and every you know every time
down the court he's trying to score and
he was the one guy I felt like I really
didn't have a weakness he could go right
go left over either shoulder in the post
could hit crazy shots you know contested
from three-pointer like you just you
just had to like you had to sort of have
amnesia sometimes you had to just get
over the fact that he was gonna hit
tough shots and but he was the ultimate
challenge no doubt not to take anything
away from LeBron I didn't guard Jordan
as much but Kobe was that good plus I
had one ankle I got a bad ankle I'm 37
years old you know and they putting me
on Kobe Bryant like that was unfair feel
sorry for you I mean I think there was a
respect there yeah but he you know he
was relentless and Laettner said and you
watch the interview with later that you
were pressured to come back after that
first surgery on your ankle yeah I
remember he wouldn't tell he wouldn't
name names to tell the whole story need
a whole hour to go through that ordeal
but yeah that that whole situation and
I'm gonna tell it at some point write a
book about it but it was horribly
mismanaged and I still remember we were
in the playoffs against Miami and it was
you know and my ankle had been bothering
me up until that point and we were
coming back from a practice that
Laettner was like a minute like you need
to take it he's like you're not right
and you know and and so I ended up
playing in that game too and that's when
you know I didn't play anymore and I had
to have surgery but I should have but he
thought you might lose your foot I mean
I could this was really upset no I a
staph infection I went septic you know
like it was the hole and this was three
years later after numerous surgeries so
yeah it was scary and it was a point day
where you know yeah you kind of thought
I would possible so because you were
people don't realize and maybe they
forget you were on the road to being
you're not Michael Jordan right but your
your ear in the conversation of most
complete player in the game
you know rebounds assists scoring you
you play defense there's no weakness
you're a great teammate and then this
happened like you had four or five years
could I get that like my kids my
daughter my 17 year old shell you know
every once in a while she'll go on
youtube or something and she'll be like
dad you actually were a pretty good
player Kobe tortured me when I'm 38 yeah
they didn't see that so I appreciate
that show her GQ magazine or show her
that the kid and play haircut yeah well
I won't show her that but now I mean it
was it was a good time I think for me
four years in college coming into the
league having success you know early on
and getting better I felt like my sixth
year in Detroit like I finally got into
a point where the game was really really
easy you were hanging and then you know
and then I had the injury ordeal and did
you think you were as good as Jordan at
that time you know what I think certain
players when you're at a certain level
and we top five ten whatever top 20 in
the league like you feel like you're the
best player on the court and so when I
stepped on the court even against Jordan
I always felt like I was a better player
and when I came back whether I was the
better player or not that's what I felt
but when I came back after four years
you think the Derrick Rose and all the
stuff he went that was two years yeah so
I had four years of just you know
injuries you know the body betraying you
you lose the confidence in your body but
you also lose the confidence in who you
are so instead of feeling like I'm that
best player yeah now I'm just I'm just
happy to be back you want
Koby and so I lost a little bit of that
edge that's necessary I think to be at
that bad level you were gonna tell me a
Jordan's story when I first saw you
today right you want it let's let's end
this segment with that so by the way I
have a basketball court here right
I would like to recreate the Duke
Kentucky play but I'm gonna have you run
the defense like what did Kentucky do
wrong on that play where Christian hits
the shot okay okay all right and by the
way
Laettner didn't that wasn't tough what
Laettner did right you had the hard
thing you had to you had to find the
open man you can't you should be called
the pass you can't make this and then as
he caught it
he took a dribble I'm like no but now he
that was that was an unbelievable moment
and unbelievable performance will show
that during the live looking all right
your Jordans story before we take a
break
so Jordan I'm playing in Orlando it's
his last year we play them in Orlando
first and I'm blocking his shot like I'm
locking him up oh I'm doing my thing
again I'd like to shot like three or
four times Oh like I'm having my way
against him defensively not granted he's
40 years old but I'm feeling good about
myself so fast forward a month later
were in DC
my ankle we would go to a doctor in
Baltimore and basically he tells me I'm
done like my ankles
you know once again it's not healed it's
broken I have to have surgery but I
wanted to play against Jordan one last
time and so we're playing the Wizards on
as a TNT game don't you want to go out
where you dominate him no my ego
one ankle give me a bunch of mo trouble
out here and when I tell you he torched
me in that first quarter like literally
he gave me 20 points in the first
quarter on the same play like he just
ran the same play every time and did
this like you know and I could not guard
him and so literally I checked out of
the game at the end of the first quarter
and I didn't even go to the bit I just
walked back to the locker I was like a
couple days later but it was like I
wanted to guard Jordan one last time and
you're right I shouldn't have I should
have just let that go
did he know you were wounded and
probably did because he wouldn't add me
every move like it was a do anything
different it was the same and I had
nothing for Jordan probably had your
x-rays in the locker room probably
probably knew exactly I'm surprised you
didn't send somebody for me to come back
out during the live look in will
recreate the Kentucky Duke play where
grant makes the unbelievable pass and
Laettner hits a decent jumper okay so
we're gonna recreate right one of the
great passes in NCAA history and a
decent shot by later this is Kentucky
Duke and so you're me with your meet
with the better haircut yeah not gonna
put somebody on the basketball no we're
gonna go two scenarios you're Rick
Pitino so you drop the defense okay I'm
still gonna double-team later indecision
I'm not gonna put somebody on grand not
know oh but this guy right here has not
missed a shot the whole game he's ten
for tenth nine for nine three and four
tension that's it so he is not going to
get the ball okay but I'm gonna put
somebody in front of him well and I'm
gonna put somebody in back yeah belfry
on him in front of him and I'm gonna say
do not let him touch the ball okay you
whatever you do he does not get it guy
Pitino say it what Pitino said in the
delay the time I was don't foul
oh there you go we got it yeah you don't
get a championship if you don't get here
we don't get that mclovin would you get
it for more Dan Patrick show to the
audience Channel 239 on Direct TV or
download the Dan Patrick show app
[Music]